se acerca el fin del ciclo escolar y mi
maestro de biología está preparando las
calificaciones estoy un poco nerviosa
porque ya quiero saber mi calificación
final así que me adelantaría calcularla
me ayudas a hacerlo mi maestro considera
varias actividades para asignar una
calificación y cada una vale una parte
del 100% los exámenes valen 40% las
participaciones 20 los proyectos 15 y
las tareas 25 el promedio de mis
exámenes fue 8 de participación en clase
9 de los proyectos 10 y de tareas 9
como te puedes dar cuenta mi
calificación más alta es el 10 que tengo
en proyectos pero no podríamos decir que
vale más que por ejemplo los exámenes
aunque mi calificación es de 8 y es la
más baja el porcentaje al que equivale
es el más alto por lo tanto aunque en
los proyectos saque 10 la calificación
de exámenes vale más así que no tengo
asegurada una buena calificación final
cómo podemos saber exactamente qué
calificación obtendré necesitamos
calcular la media ponderada y esto nos
va a servir porque nuestro 100% no se
divide en porcentajes iguales entre cada
actividad veamos cómo se calcula para
poder encontrar mi calificación final lo
único que debemos hacer es multiplicar
cada uno de los promedios por el
porcentaje que representa empecemos
40% de los exámenes por 8 es igual a 320
el 20% de participación en clase lo
multiplicamos por 9 y el resultado de
180 en el caso de los proyectos
multiplicamos 15 por 10 y obtenemos 150
muy bien ya sólo nos falta multiplicar
25% por 9 y nos da 225 perfecto ahora
que tenemos estos cálculos sumaremos
cada uno para tener un total 320 más 180
más 150 más 225 es igual a 875 de la
suma obtenemos 875 pero ahí no termina
875 no puede ser la media ponderada o
sea mi calificación final nos falta un
paso muy simple hay que dividir 875
entre 100 que es el total por lo que 875
entre 100 es igual a 8.75
y así 8.75 representa la media ponderada
uff qué bien eso quiere decir que mi
calificación final de biología será 8.75
ahora pon mucha atención cuando tienes
una media ponderada se expresa de la
siguiente forma utilizando los datos que
tenemos de las calificaciones y los
porcentajes sería 40 por 8 más 20 por 9
más 15 por 10 más 25 por 9 y todo esto
entre 40 más 20 más 15 25 es igual a 875
entre 100 si hacemos la división resulta
8.75 te invito a que siga practicando
recuerda que cuando tienes elementos que
no son equivalentes dentro de un
conjunto de datos tendrás que calcular
una media ponderada mucho éxito